لكن لماذا انهارت العديد من المباني في
تركيا عقب الزلازل بصرف النظر عن السبب
الواضح طبعا هو ان اي زلزال بقوه 7.8 درجه
بامكانه تسويه المباني بالارض تحقيق لبي
بي سي سله الضوء على التحايل على معايير
السلامه الانشائيه في تركيا وفقا للتقارير
سمحت الحكومه التركيه ببناء مبانئ بدون
شهادات السلامه المطلوبه مقابل رسوم ما
جعل حتى المباني الجديده معرضه للانهيار
وتم تمرير مثل تلك الاعفاءات القانونيه
الفعاله منذ الستينات من القرن الماضي
اخرها في عام 2018
ولا طالما حذر المنتقدون من ان قرارات
العفو هذه قد تؤدي الى وقوع كارثه في حاله
وقوع زلزال كبير في سياق اخر قال رئيس
اتحاد غرف المهندسين الاتراك ومخططي المدن
في اسطنبول انه تم منحه ما يصل الى 75 الف
اعفاء لمبان في جميع انحاء منطقه الزلزال
المتضرره في جنوب تركيا